um he's uh of course he needs no
introduction he's one of the giants of
the field uh
so john is uh is a is a is a theorist
but
but i think his his work has reached out
in many ways to
both the foundations of physics as well
as to
to more practical quantum computing you
know between his work and
error correction and quantum gravity and
nisk devices
and so uh you know obviously today is
probably reaching out more towards the
practical side um i should say
one thing that's really remarkable about
where john is that um
i think an astounding fraction of the of
the people in the field
especially on the physics side have been
have been mentored by him so
john looking forward to your talk
all right thank you umesh for the uh
the kind introduction i guess i can't
resist mentioning that as
astonishing fraction of people in the
field on the computer science side have
been mentored by you
i'm going to talk mostly about
some work i've done with robert huang
and richard kuhn
my collaborators are far more
knowledgeable than i am about
machine learning and probability theory
this has been a very
illuminating and exciting collaboration
for me
and in the second half of the talk i'll
say some things about some work we're
currently doing
joined by victor albert and giacomo
torla
so the theme is classical shadows of
quantum state so
what does that mean why should we care
about it
well what i want to describe is an
efficient and experimentally feasible
way
of translating a quantum many-body state
into succinct
classical language while retaining
with that classical description the
ability to predict
many useful properties of the state
is that useful we're in the nisk era
we are aspiring to achieve quantum
advantage
in platforms perhaps in the next few
years
and perhaps our best hope for doing so
is by means of hybrid quantum classical
algorithms to use our classical
computers to the extent that we can and
then
boost their power with quantum devices
used as coprocessors so if it's
experimentally feasible
to trade quantum for classical resources
while not compromising our ability to
carry out an application
it's likely to be beneficial to do so
and with these classical shadows we can
improve the efficiency
of variational methods for solving
optimization problems
and by converting from quantum to
classical language we can then use
classical machine learning tools
to address quantum problems
so what we're shooting for is some
tractable way of translating from
quantum
to classical data specifically we would
like
if we have a quantum many body state
in our quantum device to be able with a
small number of measurements which are
easy to do experimentally to obtain this
classical description from which we can
predict many properties of the many-body
state
we want that classical description to be
succinct and easy to store and we want
our predictions to be easy to do by
classical computation and we want a
rigorous guarantee
that our predictions have a small error
with high probability
the kinds of properties we might want to
predict are fidelity with
target state or expectation values of
local observables or a viewpoint
correlation functions or
entanglement entropy and the types of
resources we'll care about
is how difficult is it to do this
translation from quantum to classical
on our quantum platform how many copies
of the quantum state will we need to be
able to make
accurate predictions how much classical
memory we'll need and how much classical
processing
to derive those predictions
so as you know there is a procedure for
translating a quantum state into
classical language doing full quantum
state
tomography and then we can use that
classical description to derive
properties of the quantum state
but full quantum state tomography is
very inefficient for
many body systems
the description itself is exponential
in the number of qubits the system size
the number of samples that we need to
extract accurate predictions is also
exponential and system size the amount
of classical storage and classical
processing we need to do to compute
predictions
is also exponential so that's not a
practical procedure for
systems with many qubits
there is the ingenious idea of shadow
tomography
which scott developed and analyzed
where one doesn't try to learn a
complete description of the quantum
state but the goal instead is to make
accurate predictions for expectation
values of
some set of operators and
remarkably in that case it turns out the
number of samples that we need to make
those
predictions scales polynomially with the
system size
and furthermore in order to predict m
properties
we only need a poly logarithmic number
of
copies of the state however
this is still not a practical procedure
because it requires
very expensive quantum processing
including quantum computations that
act across multiple copies of the state
and a lot of storage and post-processing
to make predictions
there are also heuristic ideas for
extracting predictions from quantum
states like
neural network quantum state tomography
one can
perform some set of measurements to
train a neural network
which can then be used to predict
additional properties of the state and
in practice that may work well in some
instances
and furthermore the quantum experiments
that we need to do
to train the neural network are feasible
but we don't really have a rigorous
theory of neural network quantum state
tomography it's a heuristic
procedure and so we can't say in general
for some input quantum state how many
samples we'll need
how much storage and how much processing
in order to get
good predictions with high success
probability
so what we'd want is a procedure where
we can
prove that it's efficient both in terms
of the quantum processing we need to do
on the input state
the amount of classical storage we need
and the amount of classical processing
we need which will enable us to learn
some classical representation of
an unknown input state from a small
number of measurements and then use it
to predict many properties of the state
and the result that we proved about a
year ago shows that this is possible
under
certain conditions that if we want
to predict expectation values of
a list of observables and to do so
with a small constant error with a high
success probability
then the number of copies of the state
that we need to do the number of
repetitions of the experiment
is just logarithmic in the number of
properties to be predicted
but there's a catch there's a pre-factor
here which depends on something i've
called the shadow norm
and we require all of the operators to
have a
sufficiently small shadow norm i'll
explain what i mean by the shadow norm
later on but it turns out for
some cases of interest that the shadow
norm
is actually a constant independent of
system size
so in that case we're saying that we can
predict
m properties with the border log n
measurements
and the sample complexity that we need
doesn't depend on the system size
at all the experiments are
efficient on the quantum platform and
the classical storage
and processing are also reasonable
if i wanted to just naively measure and
different
observables one by one i would need a
number
of copies of the state in the millions
but we're saying
that we only need a few times the log of
them
copies of the state to get accurate
predictions with high success
probability
a big improvement so let's see how this
procedure
works let's say we have n copies of the
state and so we repeatedly
do experiments on the state in the
following way there are
a number of variants on the procedure
but they all have in common that it's a
randomized protocol
and there's some ensemble of unitaries
that we can choose from
and in each run of the experiment we
select a unitary from that ensemble
we want this unitary to be something we
can really do in the lab
and we also want it to be something that
we can describe succinctly
in terms of classical data we apply that
unitary to the system and then we
measure in the computational basis
if it's an n-cubit state we collect n
bits of data
in doing so and then we obtain a
snapshot of the state
which is the result of applying the
inverse of the unitary to
that measurement outcome and this is
something that i do acting on the
classical data
the unitary is something i can
efficiently describe
and invert and so i can apply that
unitary
to the bit string to get this snapshot
and the full collection of all
and snapshots is what i'm calling the
classical
shadow so let's note for later reference
that if i consider averaging over all
the unitaries
in the ensemble and also averaging over
the measurement outcomes that defines
some channel
acting on the input quantum state some
cptp
map so again what we're going
to want to do is we have this very
complex
quantum beast in the lab and what we do
with it
time after time is we apply some unitary
chosen from our ensemble and then we do
computational basis measurement that
gives us a snapshot and then we do it
again
and again and that collection of
snapshots
is the classical shadow
so to make it even more concrete
let's suppose for example that i have
some quantum state which lives on the
equator of the bloch sphere
and our ensemble of unitaries is the
identity
and a 90 degree rotation about the
z-axis
the black sphere so depending on that
choice
of unitary i'm either measuring in the
computational basis
zero on one or in the x basis plus or
minus
and in for this particular state i'm
when i measure in the z
basis i'm more likely to get a zero less
likely to get a one
if i measure in the x basis i'm more
likely to get a plus less likely to get
a minus
but um the snapshots are zero or plus or
one or minus depending on the outcomes
of the measurements
and if i average over the choice of
measurement and also the outcomes
that defines a channel which is just a
depolarizing channel
which preserves the state with some
non-zero probability and replaces it
with a completely mixed state with the
complementary probability
so that defines a channel which causes
the state to sink
towards the origin of the bloch sphere
but without
stinking all the way to the origin
okay so we have all these snapshots what
should we do with them
well we store the snapshot succinctly in
a classical memory
and as i said averaging over the
unit ensemble of unitaries and the
measurement outcomes to find some
channel
if we our measurements are
tomographically complete
that channel will actually be an
invertible matrix
it's not invertible by a physical map
that we can do in the lab and in fact it
takes the snapshot to
an object which is not a physical
density operator
but that's okay because we don't want to
invert this channel in the lab we just
want to invert it
in our classical memory by doing some
classical processing
and we can do that and then if we
average over the choices of measurement
and the outcomes and apply the inverse
to the channel to each one of the
snapshots
the expectation value will be the input
density operator
itself so if we repeat the measurement
many times
we have a good unbiased estimator of
the state
but in order to be assured that we can
make good predictions
we have to know something about the
variance of our estimator
but here's what we're going to do to
make predictions
i have some set of operators which let's
say i can describe succinctly
classically and then for each one of
those operators
i compute its expectation value and the
result of the inverse of the channel
applied to the snapshot
now even if i know the variance
i if i don't know anything else about
the distribution i have to worry about
our predictions being corrupted
by rare large deviations from the mean
but there's a trick for dealing with
that called median of means
estimation i can take our estimates
and divide them up into many bins
and compute the average of the estimates
in each bin each one of those gives a
estimate of the expectation value
of the observable but where a large
deviation might occur
but then i take the median of all the
estimates and then in order for that
median to deviate badly from the mean we
would have to have a large deviation
in half of the bins and that becomes
exponentially
unlikely as we increase the number of
bins exponential
in the number of bins so once we have a
sufficient
size sample we can have the
probability of a large deviation under
control and in fact
that's what enables us to guarantee
that with high success probability we
can predict
a number of observables which is
exponential
in the number of repetitions of the
experiment
but the shadow norm comes in when we
attempt to
estimate the variance of our estimator
so so far i've described the procedure
abstractly to be more concrete we should
consider
particular ensembles of unitaries
so suppose we sample those unitaries
uniformly
from the clifford group
so then the procedure is i select
a random clifford transformation and
then i measure all the qubits and the
computational basis
that's equivalent to simultaneously
measuring
a randomly selected set of
commuting poly operators and i do that
many times
now the channel that that generates when
we average over the clifford
transformations and the outcomes
looks like this averaged over unitaries
averaged over
outcomes and it's an expression which is
quadratic
in the unitary u and quadratic in its
adjoint
but the clifford group has the
delightful property of being a unitary 2
design
so i can replace that average
over clifford transformations by a
uniform average
using hard measure over the unitary
group
and averages over the unitary group are
easy to compute because the only things
that survive
are unitarian variants which we can
characterize and
compute explicitly so it turns out for
this clifford measurement scenario the
corresponding channel is a polarizing
channel
with some probability of preserving the
state
some probability of replacing it by the
maximally mixed state and that's a
channel that we know how to invert
now i want to compute the variance of
our estimator
i can use the property that this inverse
of the channel is a self-adjoint
operator so i can turn the m inverse
acting on the snapshot into an m inverse
acting on the operator and for the
variance i get an expression that looks
like this
um where now there's a there's a square
of this piece so there are three
u's and three you add joints in the
expression which i need to average over
the clifford group but the clifford
group also has the delightful property
of being a unitary 3 design
so in this case as well we can replace
the averaging over the clifford group by
averaging
over the unitary group and get an
explicit
of the variance what we call the shadow
norm
and then we can optimize that overall or
maximize it over all possible
input states and that's how we estimate
the shadow norm and in this case
it's just a constant times the hilbert
schmidt norm
an example of an observable that has a
constant
hilbert schmidt norm is finding the
fidelity with some targeted pure state
we'd be interested in the case where we
can succinctly describe that
target pure state so what i'm saying in
the case of fidelity estimation is
that i can repeat my experiment
altogether n times and then i can
with some small error and a high success
probability
compute the fidelity with an
exponential and then number of target
states
and the number of copies that i need
doesn't depend on the system size at all
now the trouble is that although
clifford transformations
are nice they're still a little too hard
to do in current quantum platforms since
they
require circuits of sufficient depth we
need a circuit size which is almost
n squared we'd like to have something
simpler
that we really can do experimentally or
what could be
simpler than this we just take each one
of the qubits and decide uniformly at
random
to measure one of the poly operators x y
or z so i call that poly measurement
and in this case as well it's easy to
see what the channel is because
the this is really equivalent to doing
the single qubit clifford group and then
performing a computational basis
measurement
and again averaging over the clifford
group is the same as averaging over
the unitary group now we have a tensor
product
of depolarizing channels acting on the
end qubits
uh that's easy to invert then we can
estimate the variance
that's our shadow norm use the property
that the single cubic
clifford group is a three design to get
our estimate
and what we find in this case is that we
can relate the shadow norm
to the operator norm of the observable
that we're trying to predict
but there's also an exponential
dependence on the weight
of the observable on the number of
qubits on which it acts non-trivially
but we can make good predictions
efficiently
if we're interested in observables which
have constant weight
like if we were computing local
observables sums of local observables
two-point correlation functions and so
on
now this procedure works for estimating
arbitrary observables of
constant weight but to get some
intuition concerning
why the cost grows exponentially with
weight we can consider
the simpler special case of just
predicting
poly operators expectation values to
poly operators
so if we have some list of poly
operators that we want to be able to
protect
or want to be able to predict and
they're all of constant weight
weight no larger than w here's one of
them xzzx
acting on some subset of the qubits and
acting trivially on the rest
then we do our randomized procedure and
we have some non-zero probability
of hitting the right poly operators for
in this case the
four operators on which uh
we have a non-trivial action and that
probability
of hitting the right poly operator will
go
like three to the minus the weight if
the weight is w
and in this case we don't have to bother
with median of means estimation because
we know how to characterize
the uh variance of the estimator
directly but it turns out then that we
need to repeat the
experiment in order to predict operators
of weight
no larger than w a number of times that
scales
like 3 to the w but we can predict a
number
of poly operators which is exponential
in the number of repetitions of the
experiment and that was nicely discussed
by these guys before we did our work
now that procedure applies to arbitrary
lists of poly operators
but it's often interesting to consider
poly operators that have some special
structure
we can exploit and then we might be able
to do better with a deterministic
procedure
we can arrive at such a procedure just
by de-randomizing
this randomized poly measurement
procedure
so let's say we have some a list of poly
operators
each acting on n qubits and the
randomized
protocol gives some guaranteed
performance
with high probability on our
concrete list of poly operators we want
to predict
what we can consider is fixing one of
the poly measurements to be
x y or z and then see
how the procedure performs when we
randomize the measurements on
the rest of the operators and we can
choose
the choice x y or z for that particular
qubit in that particular poly operator
to give the best performance and
we can do that iteratively since we can
compute
bounds on the performance efficiently we
can efficiently step through our list of
poly operators one qubit at a time and
each time uh replace the randomized
poly measurement by some fixed poly
measurement
and continue to randomize over the rest
and then
when we've stepped through the whole
list we completely do randomize
the procedure and
here's an example of a case in which
that helps
this is inspired by an actual experiment
that was done by the innsbruck group
a couple of years ago with an ion trap
with 20 ions they were specifically
motivated
by studying electrodynamics in one
dimension
but for our purposes we don't have to
worry about that
this is really a spin system
a set of qubits where the hamiltonian is
sum of two qubit operators but without a
geometric locality constraint
so the hamiltonian has of order n
squared terms in it
and then they did a very clever thing in
this experiment
they did a variational search for states
which have low energy but they also
search for states that have a low value
of the variance
of the hamiltonian searching for the
case in which
the expectation value of the hamiltonian
squared
is close to the square of the
expectation value of the hamiltonian
when that variance is small it means
we're close to having
an eigenstate of the hamiltonian so
starting with some
initial state and carrying out this
variational procedure we can find not
just
the ground state the lowest energy state
but other low-lying energy eigen states
and that's what they did but this is a
pretty expensive procedure
the hamiltonian has and order n squared
terms the hamiltonian squared has order
n to the fourth terms
that's a lot of poly operators that we
need to predict
and in the experiment they hand crafted
a procedure for extracting
the expectation values of poly operators
that they needed to find the variance of
the hamiltonian
and actually their procedure does better
for modest system size than the
shadow classical shadow procedure but as
the system size
grows in the case of the classical
shadow protocol
we're trying to estimate um a border
end of the four poly operators but the
number of experiments that we
need just grows logarithmically with
that while
their procedure actually has a
dependence which is linear in system
size so classical shadows do
considerably better for large system
size
but there's enough structure in the poly
operators in this case that we can get a
big gain
by derandomizing so if we do randomize
the
poly measurement of the way i described
how we can get
a big reduction by about an order of
magnitude
in the number of experiments that we
need to do
to get a desired error
we also looked at some applications to
quantum chemistry
this is a case where the classical
shadow method might be challenged
because
quantum chemistry problem is a problem
in electronic structure
it's a hamiltonian for a system of
fermions and we have to encode that in
qubits
and when we do so some of the poly
operators that arise have
relatively high weight which means the
that might be dis advantageous for the
randomized protocol
um this is an indication of the
performance of the classical shadow
method
indicating the error in the estimation
of the ground state energy
for some particular benchmark molecule
where it can be described by a small
enough number of qubits so we can do
exact diagonalization so we know what
the right answer is and we can
test our procedure for that benchmark
example
the ibm group pointed out that you can
actually do better because
you can put some bias into the classical
shadow protocol
the poly operators that arise are more
likely
to be supported on x than on
y and z so we can instead of using a
uniform distribution on x y and z by
biasing the distribution
we have a better chance of hitting the
poly operators that
we're interested in but if we take the
classical shadow protocol and we
de-randomize it then we can do
considerably better
and with a smaller number of experiments
get to the desired error
now i've been talking about predicting
expectation values
of operators linear functions of the
density operator
but i should emphasize that we can also
estimate
nonlinear functions in fact if i want to
compute a function which is quadratic in
the density operator
we can just think of that as the
expectation value
of an observable in
the state which is the tensor product of
two copies of raw
and we can use classical shadows to
estimate that quantity
by taking pairs of snapshots and
replacing
the first copy of row by one snapshot
and
the second copy by another distinct
snapshot
and then average over all the ways of
choosing the pairs of snapshots to get
our estimate
and in that case as well we can do
an estimate of the variance of the
estimator
and get some performance guarantee
on um our predictions we can use that
for example
to estimate rainy entropies
of subsystems and in a collaboration
with the
inspire group we applied that to
studying entanglement dynamics
after a quench in an ion trap
experiment the cost of
estimating the entropy of cost of our
subsystem
still grows exponentially with the
number of qubits
in the subsystem and can't get around
that but
the classical shadow procedure does
provide a more efficient
way of estimating randy entropies than
previously used
randomized measurement protocols
so now i'd like to talk about something
we've been thinking about lately
which is applying machine learning to
quantum problems and this is something
that
has attracted a lot of attention the
last a few years and there are
promising results but most what's been
done
is heuristic and we were interested
whether there are situations
in which we can show that machine
learning
used to solve a quantum problem really
does
work efficiently and we found a couple
of settings
in which that's true which i'll explain
the first setting is the problem of
learning
properties of a quantum ground state
so let's suppose that there's some
family
of hamiltonians they're all local
hamiltonians in some finite dimension
and we're guaranteed that there's
an energy gap a constant gap between the
ground state and the first excited state
for all the hamiltonians in the family
they are smoothly parametrized by some
set of real parameters
there may be many field parameters could
live in a high dimensional
parameter space and
what we want to do is predict properties
of the ground states for
various values of x during the training
stage
we're going to suppose that we are
provided with
a sample of the ground state for some
value of x
that we want to sample from and that's
something that of course would have to
be prepared
on a quantum platform somehow and our
goal
is after training to predict properties
of the ground state
for new values of x beyond those that
are encountered
during training so for example we might
want to learn
the expectation value of some sum of
local operators
in the ground state at that new value of
x
and the idea that we studied is
to convert the training states to their
classical shadows
and to train on the classical shadows
and then during the prediction phase we
don't use the quantum platform at all
rather we're
given some value of x and a description
of the local hamiltonian and then we
want to use
our classical learning algorithm to
predict
the classical shadow for a new value of
x
and then that classical shadow can be
used to predict
many properties of the ground state for
that
new value of x
it turns out that this learning really
is efficient
uh we can get by with a
amount of training data which scales
reasonably with
the system size and with the dimension
of the parameter space if we're assured
that the properties that we want to
predict
do not vary too rapidly as a function in
the parameter space
and we can actually prove that that's
true
for the case of expectation values of
local operators
in the ground state of a finite
dimensional gap local hamiltonian
or in fact for any uh state as a
function of x which is spectrally
isolated from
other eigenstates throughout the
parameter regime
that guarantee that the function very
slowly
is obtained using the method called
quasi-adiabatic
continuation or spectral flow
but once we know it's true then we're
assured that this
prediction procedure is really efficient
all the learning is classical
we learn using the classical shadows
as inputs and we predict classical
shadows for the new values of x
but we still need the quantum platform
to somehow prepare the ground state
for the values of x encountered during
training
and to extract the classical shadow by
measuring the ground state
so we've done some numerical experiments
to see how well this
works here's one example it's an example
chosen because it corresponds to a
system studied in a real
experiment it's an array of rydberg
atoms
altogether 51 atoms held in a tweezer
array
in one dimension you don't have to worry
about that so much you can just think
about it
as a system with
51 qubits with a hamiltonian
that aside from the over
overall scale is parameterized by
two real parameters and
as we vary these parameters as we
increase
one of those that favors that the qubits
take the value
a one over taking the value zero but as
we to increase the other parameter that
dis favors
two ones sitting at neighboring sites in
the chain or even nearby
sites in the chain so there's a
competition between those two effects
which gives rise to an interesting phase
structure
as i've indicated here
so what we do is we select
some points in this parameter space
that's our training data
those are the points that are shown by
circles which have the
dark boundary around them they're all
together
20 such points selected here and then
after training we want to predict
properties at new values of the
parameters
and those are the ones indicated by the
cross
the diamond and the star
now in this case it's 51 cubits but it's
a one-dimensional chain so you can use
dmrg
to compute accurately the exact
properties
of the system and estimate in particular
using dmrg the expectation values are
local
observable so we know what the right
answers are and
we want to test how well our training
procedure
performs so we can use the classical
shadow
after training to predict a variety of
different local operators but
just to get an idea of how it works
let's say we want to
predict site by sight the expectation
value of the poly operator z
um for the point indicated by the
diamond
uh you can look here and the solid curve
is
the right answer that we get from the
dmrg
calculation and the diamonds are
the predictions that come out of our
prediction model
and you can see they match up with the
dmrg
results pretty well if we did something
more naive
if we tried to predict at the diamond
point just using the
closest buy point in the
uh training space then we wouldn't do
very well at all
um that's shown in the next plot it's
the same dmrg
data but here is the uh the data from
the
neighboring point which doesn't match up
with the right answer very well
and here similarly we can look at the
point indicated by cross
this is actually in the
phase of the system where ones and zeros
want to alternate in the ground state
one zero one zero one zero
and so when we look at the expectation
value of z
we see these oscillations again the
solid curve
is the result from dmrt and the crosses
are the result from the prediction model
and if we just use this nearby pi point
to try
to predict uh we don't do very well at
all so the prediction model really is
leveraging
the results uh from the training sample
beyond just the
points which are closest by now the
truth is in this case our rigorous
theory does not
directly apply it doesn't guarantee that
we'll get good predictions
and the reason is that there are phase
transitions in this parameter space
the theory applies if we have a
constant spectral gap throughout the
parameter region
that we're sampling from and that's not
the case here because they're really
three phases but we find uh nevertheless
that the predictions work pretty well
even though
some of the training data is coming from
other phases
that wasn't guaranteed to work but it
works pretty well
the other thing i'd like to discuss is
using machine learning to
identify quantum phases of matter
so the idea here is that during training
we are offered samples of quantum states
which are representatives of either
of either one of two possible phases
let's say
a and b and those samples that we have
during training are labeled so we know
which ones come from phase a
and which ones come from phase b and
then after training
our goal is when we encounter a new
quantum state that
doesn't carry a label we are supposed to
predict that face label
with good accuracy again the idea is
to take the quantum states that we
encounter
during training convert them efficiently
in our um experimental platform
into a classical shadow and then to
learn to classify the shadows
and then during prediction when we have
a new
quantum state we convert it to its
classical shadow
and then we try to assign the right
label labeled to the shadow
the procedure we apply to learn here is
kind of a standard scenario and learning
theory
we take the input data during
training
and prediction and we map that
to a high dimensional feature space but
the input data here is not the quantum
state
itself but it's classical shadow
and then in this higher dimensional
feature space
we try to find a linear classifying
function
a hyperplane in the feature space that
separates the data from the two
phases with phase a points on one side
of the hyperplane and phase b
points on the other side and
if the um
points from either phase don't come too
close to the hyperplane
then it's relatively easy to learn
on that linear function that classifies
into phases
now to show whether this will really
work we need an assumption
which is physically motivated and that
is that there is
some classifying function that can be
used to identify
phases which is a polynomial
in few body marginal density operators
we don't have to know that function in
advance we're going to learn it
but to guarantee that this procedure
will work
we need to know that it exists
when the type of thing i might be
interested in
is distinguishing a trivial phase from a
topological phase
and it's often said that in order to
identify a topological phase i need some
kind of
non-linear or sorry um
some non-local order parameter to
identify it
what really happens though is as long as
the correlation length is finite
in the topological or trivial phase
then we can look at a volume which maybe
is a little bit larger than the
correlation volume
and that already suffices to distinguish
the two phases
an example of that would be in the case
of the topological phase we can
compute something called the topological
entanglement entropy
which is somewhat different scaling than
entropy in the trivial phase
so we can tell the difference and that
scaling already kicks in
when we consider subsystems with the
size
larger than the correlation length so we
have to assume that such
a classifying function exists but if it
is
we can build our feature map so that
it's guaranteed the
learning will be efficient meaning the
amount of training
data and the classical processing
that are required are polynomial in the
system size
as we get closer to a phase boundary
what we expect to happen
is that we have to look at larger and
larger subsystems in order to
distinguish the phases and then the
learning gets
more and more difficult but for a fixed
correlation length we can efficiently
learn to distinguish the trivial
and topological faces for example
so again we did some numerical
experiments
in particular the case of trying to
distinguish
the trivial phase from the
toric code topologically ordered
phase now
what it's uh one way of defining what
you mean by topological order
is that it's not possible starting with
a
trivial state a product state to create
a state in the topologically ordered
phase
with a local circuit that has constant
depth
now here of course we're considering
some finite system size so exactly what
you mean
by uh constant depth is a little murky
in the numerical experiments we
considered
the tory code on a 10 by 10 lattice
so the code distance is 10 they're 200
cubits
and we can take the
uh exactly solved a katayath model as a
representative
of the topologically non-trivial phase
and then we can consider
applying some low depth circuit to that
state to get some other representative
of the topological phase
and likewise we can start with a
representative of the trivial phase a
product state
and apply some local low depth circuit
to that
and then what we expect is that if the
circuits are
of sufficiently low depth we will be
able to
classify the states to tell the
difference between the topological and
trivial states
so what's shown over here on the left
is that we take the feature space
um to which our classical shadows are
mapped
and we project
the geometry of that feature space down
to
a few dimensions two dimensions in this
case
and you can see that the
representatives of the topological phase
are well separated from
those in the trivial phase so it's not
that difficult
to learn a linear function to find a
hyperplane that
that separates them effectively what's
shown over here on the right
is as we increase the circuit size
how the distinguishability between the
two phases
is a compromise this is
actually just projecting down to a one
dimension
but with uh the data arranged in a way
that gives you a visualization
of how the data is distributed in that
one dimension
so remember i'm talking about
the case where the code distance is 10
the case where i have uh
the zero depth circuit applied that just
means i have catio storage code
and a product state and those are easy
to tell apart when we take their
classical shadows
but then as we apply circuits of
increasing depth to both
the top logical state and the trivial
state
the ability to distinguish gets uh gets
worse and worse and when
the data here and is actually shown for
the case
where the circuit that's applied has
depth three we can still separate the
two pretty well
but by the time we get up to a depth
which is about half
of the code distance then our ability to
predict is
being badly compromised
okay so our main results
from studying applications of machine
learning quantum problems
are summarized here one theorem
concerns learning properties of ground
states a statement is
that for any smooth family of
hamiltonians
in a finite spatial dimension
there are local hamiltonians i should
have said
um where there's a constant spectral gap
there's a classical machine learning
algorithm which can
learn to predict an efficient classical
representation
of the ground state that can be used to
approximate few body
reduce density operators up to a
constant error
and the amount of training data and the
computation that we need
is polynomial in the dimension of
the parameter space and linear in the
system size
now the procedure is that during
training
we take the input states we
translate them into classical shader
shadows and we actually train on the
classical shadows
and in the prediction phase um we don't
use the quantum platform
at all rather we predict for a new value
of x what the classical shadow is
and then we can use that to predict
properties
and the second result concerns
identifying quantum phases
of matter and it says that if there
exists a polynomial function of
few body reduced density operators that
does classify phases
then there's a classical machine
learning algorithm that
can learn that and can predict phases
accurately
and the required amount of training data
and the computation time
are polynomial in the system size
and again the procedure is to take an
input state during
training or prediction and to translate
it into a classical shadow
and we learn to
classify the classical shadows during
training and then we can predict the cri
the correct
label uh when we get new input classical
shadows in the prediction phase
uh hi uh john there's a there's a
question on the q a
about this so uh fredrik asks
is there some direct connection to those
ground states of being a
an area law and being in principle
represented by
representable via tensor network
um
no so actually so here's an important
point
um
we can learn properties of ground states
by using the training data which would
be hard to learn
if we didn't have the training data so
if we only had the description of the
hamiltonian
and we tried to construct an
approximation to the ground state and
use that to predict properties
that might be a very hard problem but
what we're learning is that if we have
a quantum platform which provides us
with samples of the quantum state then
by measuring those and by doing
measurements that are
not so difficult for a real quantum
platform then we can proceed to
make predictions about the properties of
hamiltonians in this parametrized family
even though we couldn't do that directly
without making use of the quantum
platform
in fact um we did the following thing
just uh to illustrate the point
you can encode in a quantum state
a solution to a factoring problem
and you can choose that to be a ground
state
of some suitable local hamiltonian
and furthermore because we can use
shore's algorithm
that state could be easy to prepare in a
quantum platform and
now we uh now are given
uh samples of that easy to prepare
quantum state easy to prepare on a
quantum platform
and by measuring them and then training
on the classical shadows
we can actually solve the factoring
problem
but we were able to do that because it
was encoded in the quantum state itself
so that's an illustration
of how by training on this classical
data
we can do things that we couldn't do if
we didn't have access to the quantum
platform
at all
i think i was done with this slide right
okay actually i'm done with the talk
so here's a summary so i've told you
about classical shadows of quantum
states
this is a procedure which is actually
feasible in the lab
for translating a state from quantum
language into succinct
classical language and that classical
data
can be easily stored and by doing
efficient processing
if we consider some list of properties
that have
satisfy a suitable criterion then we can
predict accurately with a high
probability of success
and properties with just measurements of
order log m copies of the quantum state
i didn't actually talk about this but we
can show that the number of copies is
actually
asymptotically optimal if we're limited
to
measuring the states one at a time we
can do better if we can make entangling
measurements across multiple copies but
that would be
much harder to do with the quantum
platform
the sample complexity and the classical
processing time
for making predictions can improve on
methods that have been used previously
and with classical machine learning
combined with classical
shadows we can effectively address some
quantum many body problems
now this talk has been about making
predictions and
i'll predict that classical shadows will
be
used fruitfully in uh the years ahead
to develop further applications of
near-term quantum platforms so thanks a
lot for listening
great thank you that's that was a
fantastic talk uh
um let's see if there are if there are
any more questions
so adam or uh do you yeah
i see us soon juan has a question
you can go ahead and ask it directly
oh thank you for uh nice talk
um
sorry can you can you hear me yeah i
hear you
yeah yeah i have a question about the
learning the properties of the ground
state
um so unlike the shadow tomography
in order to predict the property you
need to somehow interpolate or
or extrapolate within the parameter
space of the hamiltonian in your case is
x
so could you explain how how you
smoothly interpolate those data from the
shadow tomography instead
how we smoothly interpolate the data um
well the um as i said
we need the feature that
the properties that we're going to
predict with the classical shadow
actually have
some bounded gradient um
as a function of the parameters which
you know label the
family of hamiltonians so really what we
do
is um is fourier analysis
knowing that um
bound on the gradient we can
reconstruct the um
you know a smoothed uh version of the
classical shadow
in which we throw away very high wave
number
fourier components so the number of
fourier components that we actually need
to learn is uh is a reasonable number
and that's why without a lot of training
data we're able to learn a
good enough approximation to the
classical shadow that we can
make predictions thank you
yeah i see uh uh me next day hood you
wanna ask your question
cool yeah um so this might be a bit
outside your theorem but what do you
feel about that so
um if you're way for the machine
learning learning phases if your wave
function was not
generated by a deterministic hamiltonian
but by some stochastic process
so you had one shot one shadow for each
wave function
but you could still classify the states
that you get whether they're
in the topological or say um
trivial they're topological or trivial
would you still be able to use this
method do you think or
well i'm not quite sure what you mean
because there's no
there's not really a hamiltonian in the
training task there's just a bunch of
states
and um you know we're trying to classify
the states
so uh well
yeah but what you need to give instead
of a hamiltonian is
there is a stochastic process that is
parameterized by some
some um parameters x
uh and and we know that uh for certain
values of these parameters
so what is popular now for example is a
quantum circuit with measurements for
example
so so depending on what probability for
certain types of measurements you either
have a steady state that's topological
or non-topological for example but then
you just have a single
a single shot for each state you produce
so you have an ensemble
i think you can still parametrize it i
think the question makes sense i don't
know if it
actually falls into your theorem
though well i guess to decide whether it
does we have to see
um whether that would invalidate the
assumption underlying the theorem
which is that uh you know a polynomial
function
of a few body density operators
sufficient
suffices to classify um
that that's fine that's the same thing
because you have
the states you get are topological and
if i look at a reduced density matrix of
say
four or six sites and it's more than a
two-sided correlation length
then i can probably tell topological
from nontopological
but but i have just a single axis shot
right that's a problem
yeah well i don't know i mean
you're going to give me samples of these
quantum states
and if indeed there's a classifying
function which is polynomial i'll be
able to learn it
if it's you know polynomial and constant
size uh reduced density operators
even if you can only sample one from
each state once from each state
one i don't know what you mean by one
from each state i'm going to
i'm going to measure all the qubits each
time right
that's how i make the shadow but the
next time you get this state
it'll be a different state
you cannot repeat on the same state like
you can oh okay yeah so no we can that
still works if you have a question
okay so that's the only issue well
actually wait a minute i'm not no no
i'm not probably sure i'm sorry no
it's a good question in fact i didn't
say this but
uh what we actually proved is that
for each sample you have to repeat the
measurement
uh you know some sufficient number of
times yeah i'm i'm pretty sure that's
and you would think okay right so it's a
good question
i should have said this so you have to
sample enough points
but for each sample um you have to
uh in order to get from the classical
shadow a sufficiently good
representation
right um you have to predict a
sufficient number of times
and in both cases the number of times
you have to repeat
um for each copy and the total number of
samples that you need those are
polynomial and system size
but uh it you know it it couldn't uh
you you have to have enough uh
repetitions of measurements of the same
state
but with related questions is that is it
a fundamental
because as you said if you assume some
fourier
uh space and smoothness why do you need
to sample multiple times for a single
point okay
well we're talking about two different
things now i think uh
hood was asking about the second theorem
you're asking about the first
so in the case where we're trying to
learn
this you know truncated uh bandwidth
limited version of the classical shadow
to predict properties
uh it is enough to measure once
for each sample but our proof
that you can classify phases
works only if you measure each of the
copies during training a sufficient
number of times
my question is actually related to a
who's if if i may go next
um thanks adam
john you were very uh or fairly positive
in the end
about the potential use of quantum
machines for platforms
for generating the states needed for
classical shadow
tomography as you described but
these are noisy machines in practice and
i'm curious how robust your two theorems
are
in the presence of finite amount of
noise and it would not just be the
stochastic sampling or one shot that
hood asked but the kind of realistic
noises that we see in
as you call the nisk era machines i have
a second follow-up question on that
afterwards well indeed this is an
important point
and i i didn't mention it in the talk
for lack of time
uh but uh there have been a couple of
papers addressing
this including one by uh steve flamia
and collaborators i guess steve is here
and uh so what what will happen if
there's noise in general
is that our estimator will no longer be
an unbiased estimator
and so we have to in our inversion of
the channel
uh you know include some inversion of
the effect
of the noise and what uh
other authors not us have addressed
is that under uh assumptions about the
noise being sufficiently nice
like independent noise for example we
can characterize
the noise well enough to do that
inversion and get pretty good robustness
of the predictions
the follow-up which naturally arises
from what you just described is that
your procedure should also offer
classical shadows of classical systems
classical stochastic systems
in principle because the density matrix
of those can just be a statistical
distribution
but there it's known to be fairly
difficult
because of the difficulty of noise
noise is typically not biased noise is
typically not well behaved
do you actually think that they will
work in practice
well i don't know i guess it depends on
the noise uh
i uh we have not
in our uh work on classifying phases
made any claim about noise robustness at
this point
and
i don't know i would just have i don't
have a good answer i
can make uh um an optimistic uh
guess but um you can take it or leave it
uh i think if the noise is uh
you know not highly correlated
and um that uh
it might not be that different from
what i described which is we just
applied some random local circuit
uh to the state and we can still
recognize it it's in one phase or the
other
and so maybe it would be fairly robust
but um
that's not that's beyond the scope of
what we've done so far
right thanks john mohammed would you
like to go ahead and ask her
yeah it's actually related to the
previous question but more specific
and it's very naive in the second part
of your talk you showed that the
first uh principal component can tell
whether we are in topological phase or
not
how can we make sure that actually that
component corresponds to the
topological order being present or
absent and not just the artifact
of the pristine hamiltonian that we have
implemented
well in the context of the theorem um
you know that followed from the
assumption
uh you know that this polynomial
function exists
that classifies phases successfully in
other words
that you know it it takes a value which
is greater than one in one phase and
less than minus
one in the other phase and then our
feature map is designed
so that uh if such a function exists
we can learn it so maybe what you're
questioning is
uh whether to believe the assumption
or the assumption or this principle
component that i have uh now
identified corresponds to like
entanglement entropy let's say
yeah well the point of the principle
component analysis which is to
illustrate
the idea we don't make use of principle
component
analysis in the proof um you know we
just
make use of the existence of a
classifying function with certain
properties we designed the for the
feature map so that uh if it exists
we can learn it and uh i showed the
principal component analysis just as a
nice way
of illustrating um you know what happens
so the distinguishability of the phases
as we try to muck them up more and more
by you know applying um
local random circuits
okay thanks uh peter love would you like
to
admit hi john thanks for a nice talk
um you gave a nice example uh
of one of the cases where you needed the
measurement data by constructing this
factoring example do you have any
examples where
you you don't need the quantum device so
where you can
do things with classical shadows
completely classically
um i'm not sure what the
um formulation of the question is
exactly
do you know of a subset of states
where you can obtain the classical
shadows
efficiently classically
um no i still don't understand peter so
is it a question about
um whether
um
whether we have ob beyond the guarantee
that i described for
uh some states that we can describe
classically i mean if we can describe
them classically then i guess we don't
need the classical shadow necessarily
in order to predict things about them
maybe we can take take that uh you know
odd further offline uh we we should move
on to the panel but
uh before that uh thanks john for a
fantastic
presentation okay so
um so um
let me let me introduce the panelists as
uh as omit the
pin spins up the the videos of the
panelists
so